once again the House of Representatives
is set to vote today on impeaching
Donald Trump it's connected to pass it
will trigger a trial in the Senate
yesterday Donald Trump wrote a bizarre
rambling six-page letter to Nancy Pelosi
the letter was riddled with lies and
panic and it is a document that
historians should clearly be looking at
for decades to come
I've read this thing a bunch of times
because it's so out there it's so
strange it's so odd I'm not going to
read the entire letter to you but I want
to look at some sections with you one
thing about it is that it does at least
seem to be written in in Trump's style
in that it has that random
capitalization of words in the middle of
sentences and lots of exclamation points
much like in Donald Trump's Twitter
posts Donald Trump writing I write to
express my strongest and most powerful
protest against the partisan impeachment
crusade being pursued by the Democrats
in the House of Representatives this
impeachment represents an unprecedented
and unconstitutional abuse of power
completely untrue by Democrat lawmakers
capital L lawmakers unequaled in nearly
two and a half centuries of American
legislative history Donald Trump pulls
out this idea that there are that there
is something unconstitutional about what
is going on and then in the second
paragraph Donald Trump goes on to say
the articles of impeachment introduced
by the House Judiciary are not
recognizable under any standard of
constitutional theory interpretation or
jurisprudence they include no crimes no
misdemeanors and no offense is
whatsoever you have cheapened the
importance of the very ugly word
impeachment exclamation point so again
exclamation points a less common
punctuation device in presidential
letters and of course exclamation points
in serious writing of this type are a
sign that you can't really make your
arguments with logic reason and
vocabulary so you throw in exclamation
points but substantively Trump again
pulls out this idea that there are no
crimes or misdemeanors in articles of
impeachment therefore you can't impeach
that's wrong impeachment is a political
process it doesn't require criminal
wrongdoing but a recent house you
the area report does actually accuse the
president of committing federal crimes
as I discussed with you yesterday then
the letter goes on to attack Joe Biden
as strange as that is saying quote you
know full well that Vice President Biden
used his office and a billion dollars of
US aid money to coerce Ukraine into
firing the prosecutor who was digging
into the company paying his son millions
of dollars you know this because Biden
bragged about it on video Biden openly
stated I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I looked at
them and said I'm not I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money well son of
a [ __ ] he got fired and Trump goes on
to say now you were trying to impeach me
by falsely accusing me of doing what Joe
Biden has admitted he actually did now
we've already talked about this you can
disagree with the decision that was made
you can say Joe Biden shouldn't have
been part of that but Biden was there at
the direction of Barack Obama as part of
an international group that was involved
and to even remotely liken it to Donald
Trump sending Rudy his personal lawyer
to demand smears against Biden to help
Trump win an election
it's a patently ridiculous comparison
then Trump attacks Adam Schiff head of
the House Intelligence Committee saying
congressman Adam Schiff cheated and lied
all the way up to the present day even
going so far as to fraudulently make up
out of thin air my conversation with
President zalenski of Ukraine and read
this fantasy language and read this
fantasy language to Congress as though
it were said by me his shameless lies in
deception dating all the way back to the
Russia hoax is one of the main reasons
we are here today of course Schiff
didn't lie or cheat no person or elected
official is perfect but the smear
campaign against Schiff is absurd Trump
then goes on to talk about how great
minorities are doing and this is where
the rambling starts with really long
paragraphs Trump saying you and your
party are desperate to distract from
America's extraordinary economy
incredible jobs boom record stock
markets soaring confidence and
flourishing citizens your party simply
cannot compete with our record
seven million new jobs the lowest ever
unemployment for african-americans
Hispanic Americans and Asian Americans
are rebuilt military a completely
reformed VA with choice and
accountability for our great veterans
more than a hundred and seventy new
federal judges and two Supreme Court
justices on and on and on then
Trump goes on to accuse Nancy Pelosi and
Democrats of being the ones interfering
with elections a classic move of
projection saying you are the ones
interfering in America's elections you
are the ones subverting America's
democracy you are the ones capital o
obstructing justice you are the ones
bringing pain and suffering to our
republic for your own selfish personal
political and partisan gain and this
goes on and on for six pages maybe my
favorite line of the entire thing is
where Trump says more due process was
afforded to those accused in the Salem
witch trials and then lastly maybe the
one line I agree with from the letter
Trump saying 100 years from now when
people look back at this affair I want
them to understand it and learn from it
so that it can never happen to another
president again although I know it's not
what Trump meant I do hope we have
something that in the future prevents us
from ever dealing with something like
this again where a president is able to
simply ignore checks and balances carry
out a completely corrupt viola Genda
let's hope it never happens again and we
can take step one by removing Trump
which I don't see Republicans in the
Senate doing the letter must be archived
for history the letter sums up Trump's
total disregard for the law for
conventions it sums up his arrogance his
delusions of grandeur and on some level
Trump doesn't want to be Impe impeached
he knows the Senate is not likely to
convict Trump might even get a boost I
think he knows that but at the same time
on some level Trump doesn't want to be a
president impeached the letter is
riddled with lies to the point of gas
lighting it's riddled with evidence of
Trump's delusions of grandeur but it
also is a desperate president who
doesn't want to get impeached and the
letter happens too
like a monologue from Sean Hannity's fox
news show I haven't looked but it would
be very unsurprising if some of this
language was lifted straight from a
Hannity monologue but again an innocent
man doesn't write a letter with
exclamation points attacking everyone
nor do they obstruct the investigation
an innocent man would want to prove
their innocence they would cooperate
that is not what we are seeing here on
this historic day let me know what you
expect what do you make of all this
leave a reply if you're watching on
YouTube send me a tweet if you're on
Twitter at D Pakman we will take a quick
break and remember January 1st massive
membership special get notified of the
massive membership special on January 1
by signing up for our newsletter today
at david pakman.com i have a really
great offer for all of my viewers today
for 20 bucks
our friends at total AV will give you a
year subscription to their premium
antivirus service plus and this is just
the best free access to their VPN on
three of your devices when you use the
link down below the total AV antivirus
and VPN work on your desktop computer
both Mac and Windows on your Android or
iOS phones and tablets computers and
smartphones are more at risk than ever
to all sorts of attacks many people's
computers and mobile devices are
infected without you even knowing and
even Mac users are vulnerable any
computer security expert will tell you
you've got to have a layer of protection
between you and the rest of the Internet
your best bet is to go with an advanced
all-in-one service that's easy to use
where you can install it and just forget
about it and one that's been developed
by a company that actually has a proven
track record keeping phones and keeping
computers safe and that's total AV you
set it up once you don't have to worry
about viruses or spyware ransomware
adware the long list of common threats
your otherwise susceptible to and you'll
get an entire year of premium antivirus
for 20 bucks that's 80 percent off the
normal price click the link below and
maybe the best part of the entire thing
is you'll get to use their VPN
free on three of your devices keeping
you totally anonymous on the Internet
fantastic deal it's only for our viewers
from a company that's been trusted in
the computer security industry for years
check out total AV click the link right
underneath this video